most movies lean towards you they lean
towards you aggressively with their
hands around your throat trying to grab
every section of your attention these
type of films lean away from you you're
going to hold on shots too long
you're not going to cut you're creating
dead time now you're doing something
really rare you're activating the viewer
and once the viewer starts to move on
his own is so much more powerful in a
certain moment
free them you know do something
unexpected you know you you show a movie
for an hour and a half two hours with no
music at all and often at the end boom a
big blast of Mozart what are you gonna
do with something that aggressive so
like the characters in the ozu's films
never show any emotion and all sudden an
end whammo comes a big Blossom emotion
what are you gonna do with it now that
he has totally conditioned you not to
expect it